bienvenue dans parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec à mes
côtés et les à berthelot mais bonjour et
les indigents aérienne une semaine
marquée par le marathon diplomatique de
françois hollande
le chef de l'état qui a rencontré les
principaux dirigeants de la planète avec
un objectif former une coalition
internationale pour anéantir dèche la
syrie au centre de tous les débats
parlementaires l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat ont débattu cette semaine de la
prolongation des frappes aériennes une
prolongation adopté à une très large
majorité
vous le verrez deux semaines après les
attentats qui ont endeuillé la france
place à l'hommage de la nation françois
hollande a présidé ce vendredi une
cérémonie d'hommage poignante depuis les
invalides et pour commenter cette
semaine notre invité michèle alliot
marie bonjour députée européenne les
républicains du grant west ancien
ministre de la défense de l'intérieur de
la justice et des affaires étrangères
alors avant de revenir sur le détail de
cette semaine nous avons demandé à
quelques députés ce qu'ils pensent de
vous michèle alliot marie
regardez c'est une grande dame qui est
toujours très apprécié par exemple dans
le milieu des arts mais quand elle était
ministre de la défense
c'est une dame qui a une hauteur de vue
contrairement à ce qu'on pense à n'est
pas autoritaire c'est une femme qui est
généreuse mais qui est précise et claire
dans les objectifs à atteindre donc
parfois ça plaît pas toujours mais en
tout cas aller tout sauf hypocrite c'est
une femme dynamique
engagée puis son grand parcours et
galien lui a donné une hauteur de vue
qui je crois nécessaire pour le débat
politique
c'est quelqu'un effectivement qui
incarne ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui en
politique c'est à dire la droiture la
rigueur l'honnêteté intellectuelle et le
courage politique et être à la solde net
avantage ce d'être avoir été la première
femme ni des armées c'est rare quand
même et c'est une chose intéressante à
une époque où les fait passer pour une
femme de faire de la politique
après elle a eu des convictions qui sont
pas les miennes mais les a eus
elle a fait tout un parcours politique
qui était je pense ce qu'elle souhaitait
c'est un beau parcours de femmes en
politique dans un domaine où c'est pas
simple je crois que michèle alliot marie
est quelqu'un qui à côté dans la vie
publique française et notamment pour les
femmes car elle a porté haut et clair
l'intelligence féminine mais tout en
restant je lirai député de la nation
alors michèle alliot marie on vient
d'entendre ce que pensent vos collègues
qu'on a l'impression que ce qui retient
c'est que vous êtes une femme qui a
réussi en politique être une femme ça me
paraît une évidence je ne les jamais
revendiqué en tant que tel parce que je
pense que quand on fait de la politique
ce qui compte c'est de servir son pays
c'est d'essayer d'améliorer au quotidien
de la situation des gens et que l'on est
jugé sur ses résultats et non pas sur le
fait qu'on porte une jupe ou un pantalon
vous avez longtemps été députée vous
manque c'est tennistique de l'assemblée
nationale où j'ai retrouvé un hémicycle
à strasbourg l'hémicycle ça a du bon et
du mauvais
malheureusement que les débats ne sont
pas toujours à la hauteur de ce qu'il
devrait être
c'est vrai que c'est en même temps un
lieu de débat et de là c'est important
dès lors que chacun sait tenir son rôle
et sa place parce que de plus en plus
les regards sont fixés sur l'hémicycle
je vais pas vous dire que la séance des
questions d'actualité me paraît être ce
qu'il ya toujours de mieux pour incarner
la démocratie et moi ce qui m'intéresse
en politique de toute façon au delà des
débats c'est l'action l'action à l'est
par la parole et d'action aid est aussi
par les actes
michèle alliot marie nous allons
dérouler ensemble l'actualité politique
et parlementaire de la semaine lundi
jour du début du marathon diplomatique
de françois hollande
david cameron barack obama angela merkel
matteo renzi et vladimir poutine
françois hollande a fait la tournée des
principaux dirigeants politiques de la
planète dans le but de former une
coalition internationale pour anéantir
dèche une semaine diplomatique chargé
que nous raconte alex pichon une poignée
de mains très attendu le marathon
diplomatique de françois hollande
s'achève avec vladimir poutine à moscou
pour un entretien crucial
l'objectif le convaincre de rejoindre la
coalition votre dèche le terrorisme donc
est notre ennemi et nous le connaissons
il ya un an
c'est des shs état islamique
il a un territoire il a une arme et il a
des ressources et donc nous devons
cette large coalition dont j'ai parlé
frappé ce terrorisme nous sommes prêts à
cette coopération monsieur le président
et nous sommes ravis que vous soyez
venus la veille françois hollande
recevait angela merkel place de la
république pour un moment de
recueillement plus à l'elysée pour un
dîner
il a obtenu de la chancelière la
promesse d'un soutien dans la lutte
contre le groupe jihadiste
lorsque le président invite à réfléchir
aux responsabilités supplémentaires que
nous pourrions assumer et bien pour moi
c'est une véritable mission et nous
réagirons vite mais l'effort allemands
ne se déploiera pas pour l'instant au
moyen-orient la chancelière a besoin du
feu vert de son parlement pour engager
une opération militaire
c'est donc au mali que l'allemagne
enverra 650 soldats supplémentaires en
plus des 200 déjà sur place pour
soulager la france dans son effort de
guerre
le même jour françois hollande a reçu
matteo renzi le président du conseil
italien
là aussi le chef de l'état a obtenu son
soutien les deux hommes partagent un
objectif commun la destruction de dèche
mais matteo renzi a insisté au passage
sur la nécessité de régler la situation
en libye qui pourrait bientôt devenir la
prochaine urgence côté britannique cette
fois david cameron est sur la même
longueur d'onde que françois hollande
une intervention militaire est tendue à
la syrie est nécessaire face au
parlement jeudi le premier ministre
britannique a plaidé pour davantage de
soutien à la coalition
le vote aura lieu la semaine prochaine à
washington en début de semaine le
président français a rencontré barack
obama l'unité est affichée mais peu
d'engagement de la part du président
américain
mis à part sur l'intensification des
frappes et le renforcement des échanges
en matière de renseignement les deux
chefs d'état ont aussi opté pour une
aide accrue au groupe déjà présent sur
le terrain nous avons aussi décidé de
travailler avec nos partenaires de la
coalition en irak et de soutenir tous
ceux qui combattent au sol des ch et de
faire en sorte que ces forces là puisse
être
et des équipes et par l'ensemble des
pays qui veulent
sur le plan militaire détruire des ch
pas question d'envoyer des troupes au
sol françois hollande est barack obama
redoute un scénario semblable à celui
qui a suivi l'intervention américaine en
irak en 2003 michèle alliot marie après
ce marathon diplomatique que dites-vous
à françois hollande
bravo ou tout ça pour ça non je dis
d'abord cassé dans la fonction d'eux que
c'est nécessaire 3 qui serait peut-être
dû intervenir dans un déjà avant ainsi
dans la fonction parce qu'un chef d'état
doit naturellement et en particulier
quand on est dans une période de crise
parler à ses homologues et à ceux à qui
ils demandent finalement de nous
rejoindre
2 c'est nécessaire c'est nécessaire à la
fois parce que tous les pays sont
menacés c'est nécessaire aussi parce que
on a besoin d'une force global forces
militaires mais aussi force diplomatique
n'oublions pas qu'une chose c'est que
face à ces gens qui veulent attaquer les
valeurs les principes qui sont ceux de
la démocratie il est nécessaire de leur
montrer qu'il ya un front uni du monde
entier est ce que je regrette un peu
c'est que pour l'instant nous ne voyons
que des dirigeants européens et c'est
très bien
ou américains russes il faut aussi que
soient associés des dirigeants d'autres
pays et notamment des pays du monde
islamique
car depuis le début vous savez moi je
suis pratiquement depuis 2001 les
problèmes du terrorisme vous avez une
volonté de la part des dirigeants
autrefois d'al qaïda puis d'aqmi
aujourd'hui de dèche d'essayer de créer
une guerre mondiale entre le monde
occidental et le monde arabe
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans la
coalition internationale il est
nécessaire d'avoir aussi des pays du
monde arabe
enfin c'était devenu urgent on ne gagne
jamais à perdre la confiance à perdre le
dialogue avec un certain nombre de
personnes et moi j'ai regretté j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire dès le début
qu'il y ait une sorte de refus de parler
par exemple avec poutine qui joue un
rôle qu'on le veuille ou non la russie a
un rôle à jouer dans cette partie du
monde
avoir un minimum de dialogue c'est aussi
faire passer ses convictions fortes
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec poutine
on le lui dit et on le lui dit en face à
face alors je sais c'est comme ça qu'on
peut obtenir des résultats c'est ce
qu'avait fait nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il
y a eu un problème il ya quelques années
et ça avait été plus efficace que ce que
nous avons vu sur l'ukraine en
particulier on l'a vu à le dialogue avec
vladimir poutine a été renouée est ce
que les deux attentats contre les avions
russes à une semaine d'écart ont pu
faciliter les convergences avec la
france
je ne suis pas sûr que ça ait facilité
les llach avec la france où la
convergence avec la france ce que je
sais c'est que ça rend la coalition que
plus difficile je vous disais il est
important de donner ce sentiment d'un
front uni de tous les pays il est
évident que ce qui se passe entre la
russie et la turquie n'est pas une bonne
chose c'est pas mal la coalition les
divergences entre la en tous les cas ça
complique un certain nombre de choses et
il est temps que ça s'arrête
en revanche effectivement la bombe dans
le premier avion que russes et
probablement quelque chose qui a pu
renforcer une meilleure compréhension de
la nécessité d'être unis contre c'est
fou que terroristes l'objectif de
françois hollande était de former une
coalition internationale
or aujourd'hui on ne parle déjà plus de
coalition mais de coordination
ce matin le kremlin le kremlin dit que
les occidentaux ne sont pas prêts à
s'unir avec la russie dans une coalition
unique avec la syrie est ce que la
formation de cette coalition
internationale est vouée à l'échec
écoutez je pense qu'il ne faut jamais
renoncer à voir une coalition
internationale mois depuis le départ
c'est à dire avant même les attentats de
charlie hebdo j'ai toujours dit qu en
matière de lutte contre des sèche il
était nécessaire d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de pays possible mon qu'il y ait
des tensions encore une fois c'est une
réalité mais la politique c'est aussi de
choisir les priorités de façon à ce que
les urgences passe avant un certain
nombre de problèmes
aujourd'hui nous avons une priorité
absolue qui est celle de lutter contre
des shu parce qu'il y a eu des attentats
la france malheureusement on a été deux
fois victime
soyez assurés d'une chose c'est qu'il y
en aura d'autres sur notre pays ou sur
d'autres pays
aujourd'hui face à ces gens il n'y a
aucun pays
aucune ville aucun citoyen qui soit
totalement garanti il faut avoir
conscience de ça il y aura de nouveau
une action terroriste contre d'autres
pays contre d'autres villes à l'occasion
de grands événements les événements
sportifs des événements culturels des
événements politiques parce que ce que
cherchent ces gens c'est encore moi à
tuer que finalement à avoir une renommée
à faire de la communication et donc ce
qui les intéresse c'est d'avoir des
lieux en quelque sorte des événements
symboliques qui leur permettent de faire
parler d'eux en tout cas l'actualité de
la semaine a été marquée par ces
attentats du 13 novembre jusque dans
l'hémicycle même mardi est le temps fort
c'est cette intervention du premier
ministre lors des questions au
gouvernement manuel valls a réaffirmé
dans la fermeté dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et sa volonté et celle du
gouvernement de faire respecter toutes
les lois sur le territoire national on
écoute aucune excuse le doit être
cherché aucune excuse aucune excuse
social sociologique et culturelle dans
notre pays
rien ne justifie qu'on prenne des armes
et qu'on s'en prenne à ses propres
compatriotes
nous devons être non seulement un
pitoyable dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme mais aussi intransigeant
quant à l'application des lois et des
règles de la république
michèle alliot marie c'est un discours
de vérité contient manuel valls
oui je dirais enfin du réalisme quelque
part à gauche je ne sais pas si ça sera
partagée par toute l'année c'est vrai
que depuis longtemps effectivement
depuis longtemps et je le voyais comme
ministre de la justice où je payais tout
simplement comme femme politique
vous avez ce système de l'excusé
systématique et il va falloir peut-être
que christiane taubira en tiennent aussi
compte et suivent ce que dit le premier
ministre en la matière parce que nous
avons eu beaucoup de laxisme dans un
certain nombre de cas justement au nom
de l' excuses alors que les règles la
loi c'est ce qui finalement permet aux
français de vivre ensemble
et c'est ce qui permet de trouver juste
la sanction si certains qui sont
systématiquement qui est excusé comment
voulez vous que les français acceptent
finalement de se soumettre à cette loi
qui fait finalement le ciment et l'unité
de la nation
vous ne pouvez céder c'est un peu comme
sur un terrain de sport où est pas vivre
ce sans règles et bien la loi c'est ce
qui permet aussi de vivre ensemble de
partager un destin commun est d'agir
ensemble et elle doit être respectée
c'est le zéro excuses qu'il faut''
aujourd'hui savoir appliquer ce sont les
bonnes mesures qui ont été prises par
l'exécutif depuis deux semaines depuis
deux semaines l'exécutif je pense qu'il
faut le dire aussi s'est montré à la
hauteur de la situation en termes
d'attitude et de communication le
véritable problème c'est de savoir s'il
en tire les conséquences
parce que encore une fois ce que nous
disons que depuis un certain donc et
notamment depuis les attentats de
charlie hebdo on a dit oui on va faire
un certain nombre de choses et nous
voyons que tout n'a pas été mis en place
donc c'est bien au moment où il y à une
crise de dire les choses il dira bien
ensuite il est nécessaire de les
appliquer et de veiller à ce qu'elle
soit appliquée ça passe par une révision
de la constitution par exemple il faut
d'abord appliquer ce qui existe cessons
de perdre du temps à toujours vouloir
faire de nouveaux textes alors que vous
avez des textes qui peuvent être
appliqués qui devrait être appliquée et
qu'il ne sont pas ceci est valable pour
tous les gouvernements
je le dis très clairement mardi au sénat
échec de la commission mixte paritaire
sur le projet de loi immigration un
texte pourtant durci par la droite
sénatoriale flora sauvage c'est un échec
députés et sénateurs n'ont pas réussi à
trouver un accord sur le projet de loi
sur le droit des étrangers
malgré la volonté de la droite
sénatoriale de durcir le texte
les événements récents nous invite à
être beaucoup plus vigilant sur le
contrôle aux frontières
et à faire en sorte que des
personnalités indésirables ne
s'introduise pas en france en invoquant
des droits qu'en réalité ils n'ont pas
quotas d'étrangers durcissement des
conditions de regroupement familial
après les attentats du 13 novembre les
sénateurs de droite avaient espéré que
le gouvernement rejoindraient leurs
lignes sans succès ici au sénat la
majorité de droite a vu mieux la barre
très haut en détricotant le texte en
supprimant ce qui était le coeur du
dispositif c'est à dire le titre pluri
annuel de 4 ans et puis également pour
des raisons d'affichage politique en
faisant en mettant en place des mesures
qui étaient des signaux pour l'électorat
du front national comme cette histoire
de quotas comme la fin de l'aide
médicale d'état
désormais ce sont les députés qui auront
le dernier mot
le rapporteur du texte à l'assemblée
nationale explique sa position
c'est très difficile de lier le texte
concernant le droit des étrangers qui
nous est proposée par le gouvernement
depuis plusieurs mois aux événements
actuels mais ce que je ne veux pas faire
un amalgame entre le statut des
étrangers qui sont durablement dans
notre pays et les terroristes
du reste un certain nombre de ces
terroristes étaient de nationalité
française
le texte doit revenir à l'assemblée
nationale début janvier
alors le droit des étrangers 1 c'est un
vieux serpent de mer droite et gauche
n'arrive toujours pas à s'accorder sur
le sujet oui parce que là aussi je pense
que il y a un problème de réalisme qui
n'est pas forcément que accepté d'un
côté parfois que de l'autre si c'est à
dire qu'il ya souvent des positions trop
extrême alors que ce qui est nécessaire
c'est d'avoir du pragmatisme
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à des
formes d'immigration extrêmement
différente à la fois des demandeurs
d'asile qui viennent par exemple de la
syrie au parlement européen que j'écris
et je préside un groupe de travail sur
les chrétiens d'orient et sur la
tolérance religieuse ce qui va donc au
delà des chrétiens d'orient il est
évident que il y a là des priorités
d'autre part nous avons un certain
nombre d'autres immigrés qui viennent
sans avoir de papiers que parfois que
d'ailleurs aussi sans que d'avoir un
projet extrêmement précis et on a
l'impression que plus rien n'est
contrôlé si vous voulez permettre à des
gens
la fois d'être réfugié il faut mettre
les réfugiés à part je crois que tout le
monde en est conscient mais si vous
voulez permettre à des gens de rentrer
sur votre territoire pour s'assimiler à
la population parce qu'ils ont envie de
partager un certain nombre de choses
avec nous parce qu'ils sont prêts à
faire également que des efforts à
apporter quelque chose au pays
c'est une chose vous avez d'autres
personnes qui ne sont pas dans cette
situation est la moindre des choses que
l'on peut dire c'est qu'il y à une
nécessité de savoir qui est sur son
propre territoire c'est un débat que
j'ai au parlement européen
et moi je veux dire une chose c'est que
je commence à en avoir assez
j'en ai assez du double langage j'en ai
assez que ici certains y compris le
front national dont vous parliez nous
disent on a besoin de protéger les
français on a besoin protéger la
sécurité et que les mêmes votes contre
le pnr c'est à dire contre la
possibilité de contrôler les voyageurs
aériens qui viennent sur notre
territoire quand ils sont à strasbourg
alors que c'est là où il peut y avoir un
blocage et c'est la même chose pour les
socialistes on ne peut pas avoir d'un
côté un langage rassurant à l'égard des
électeurs quand on est sur le territoire
national et voté contre les mesures qui
le permettent quand on est au parlement
européen je pense que la politique c'est
aussi de dire la vérité aux gens et moi
c'est mon équipe de la politique j'ai
toujours dit ce que je pensais on est
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
c'est peut-être mais aujourd'hui nous
avons une priorité une priorité face aux
problèmes migratoires incontrôlés une
priorité face au terrorisme
c'est de savoir contrôler les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et pour ça il
faut donner les moyens nécessaires
michèle alliot-marie vous parliez des
réfugiés cette semaine manuel valls dans
un entretien au süddeutsche zeitung a
dit que la france ne pouvait pas
accueillir plus de réfugiés est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec le premier
ministre
écoutez il faut regarder ce qui est
possible de faire et lesquels peut être
que notre problème pour accueillir des
réfugiés
ça vient de ce que nous avons balle
contrôler l'immigration clandestine et
qu' il ya beaucoup moins depuis que les
socialistes sont ici beaucoup moins de
retour dans leur pays des gens qui sont
sans papiers et donc qu'ils sont des
clandestins qu'il n'y en avait
auparavant et à partir de là vous vous
gardez un certain nombre de personnes si
ce qui fait qu'il est beaucoup plus
difficile
nous avons peu de moyens pour
effectivement acquérir des autres il ya
un autre problème que je voudrais
également souligner c'est que l'on
demande de la solidarité à toute
l'europe c'est tout à fait normal mais
il faut bien voir aussi que la france
est le pays qui m'est le plus de moyens
à travers notamment sa défense nationale
pour essayer d'enrayer les
problématiques de l'exil ou de
l'immigration au départ les gens ne
viennent pas en france de guetteur ils
n'abandonnent pas leurs maisons leurs
familles leurs tons bleus leur emploi
simplement que comme ça ils viennent
parce qu'ils y sont forcées et ils ont
forcé pourquoi notamment parce que vous
avez des guerres parce que vous avez des
trafics parce que vous avez ce qu'on en
matière de défense on appelle des zones
grises qui font qu'ils ne peuvent pas
vivre en sécurité dans leur pays
donc il y a un devoir de la part de nos
pays qui est aussi d'essayer de lutter
pour permettre à ces pays de retrouver
l'autorité de l'état et pour vivre
c'est pour ça que nous avons des forces
largement déployées mais il est un peu
paradoxal que soit pratiquement nous qui
fassions le plus gros effort en matière
de défense nationale tandis que d'autres
pays nous laisse faire finalement et
nous demande le cas échéant d'aller
protéger leurs ressortissants
quand il se trouve dans un pays à
l'étranger où il se trouve en danger
donc je ne sais pas exactement quel a
été l'argument terre de manuel valls
mais moi je trouverais tout à fait
normal de dire partageons l'ensemble du
fardeau est peut-être un certain nombre
de pays qui font moins pour aller
essayer de régler des problèmes à la
demande des gouvernements dans les pays
en question bien et que ces pays fassent
un peu plus en ce qui concerne l'accueil
mais d'une façon générale il est
indispensable effectivement que
l'accueil soit fait dans des conditions
justes
c'est à dire en établissant là aussi des
priorités et en disant quand on
n'accueille pas c'est à dire quand des
gens ne remplissent pas les conditions
eh bien on doit les ramener chez eux on
passe au mercredi avec les débats à
l'assemblée et au sénat sur la syrie
le temps fort de ce mercredi à
l'assemblée comme au sénat c'est le
débat sur la prolongation ou non des
frappes aériennes en syrie ce débat
intervient dans les quatre mois qui
suivent le déclenchement de l'opération
conformément à la constitution à
l'assemblée
manuel valls était à la tribune et sans
surprise la poursuite a été voté à une
très large majorité
rim benameur écrasante majorité pour la
poursuite des frappes françaises en
syrie hommage appuyé aux militaires
français et explications de la stratégie
française
manuel valls a insisté sur la nécessité
de cette guerre
le rapport des forces sur le terrain
commence à s'inverser avec l'appui de la
coalition
les unités irakiennes et kurdes et
l'opposition modérée syriennes ont
réussi à endiguer l'expansion
territoriale de dèche neige commence
donc à reculer c'est la preuve que cette
organisation peut être vaincue et pour
cela nous devons aller encore plus loin
plus fort parce que cette armée
terroriste encore des ressources
position inconfortable pour la droite
les républicains vote la poursuite des
frappes mais critiquent la diplomatie
française le leitmotiv du nid assad ni
dèche fait une erreur nous n'avons
aucune complaisance concernant le
président syrien
mais lorsqu'on fait la guerre et que
l'on doit protéger les français des
représailles
on ne multiplie pas ses adversaires et
au surplus on ne méprise pas ses
éventuels alliés
je n'ai pas attendu le 13 novembre pour
dire que moscou devait être intégré à la
coalition internationale
au lieu de au lieu de cela nous avons
préféré engager un bras de fer avec la
russie la plupart des écologistes ont
aussi voté oui en revanche abstention
pour les dix députés front de gauche
riposté la violence terroriste par la
seule voie militaire et sans stratégie
politique visant le retour de la paix et
le développement de toute la région sera
une grave erreur
l'onu doit être placé au sens des
initiatives diplomatiques et politiques
moins d'une semaine après la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence les
députés de toutes tendances politiques
auront donc à nouveau soutenu le
gouvernement dans sa stratégie de lutte
contre le terrorisme et au sénat le vote
à une très large majorité aussi puisque
325 sénateurs se sont prononcés pour et
zéro contre alors michèle alliot marie a
on le voyait deux députés seulement
opposés à ces frappes aériennes aucun
sénateur c'est l'illustration parfaite
de l'union nationale ce poste vous savez
la république nous le voyons ce matin qu
aux invalides j'étais à la cérémonie la
république c'est se réunir
quand on est dans une situation de crise
autour d'un certain nombre de valeurs
qui sont liées à la liberté à notre idée
de l'égalité et à la fraternité
mais la démocratie c'est aussi de
débattre de la meilleure solution et
nous nous disons effectivement la gauche
n'a pas forcément la meilleure solution
en matière d'immigration en matière de
justice et en matière d'action ceci dit
il y a des éléments de bon sens il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il faut combattre
pêche
il faut le combattre d'un point de vue
aérien parce que nous avons fait un
certain nombre de frappes notamment sur
des dépôts de munitions ou autre c'est
quelque chose de nécessaire il faudra
aller au delà je lui ai toujours dit il
faudra travailler un peu seul sur le
terrain et je ne veux pas et je pense
qu'il serait contreproductif d'envoyer
des troupes françaises ou des troupes
occidentales au sol à la fois parce que
nous connaissons très mal le terrain
deuxièmement parce que vous avez des
éléments terroristes qui se dissimulent
au milieu de la population
nous avons vu ce que ça donnait en
afghanistan c'est extrêmement difficile
pour nos militaires sur le terrain de
pouvoir discerner et de pouvoir agir
d'autant que les terroristes tiennent la
population aussi par la menace
troisièmement il y a le risque d'être
ressentie comme une armée d'occupation
avec notamment des militaires je ne
parle pas des militaires français mais
beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres qui ne
connaissent pas la culture locale et qui
commettent un certain nombre de foot qui
les font rejeter donc il est
indispensable d'avoir des forces au sol
qui soient des forces de la région où
des forces venant des pays arabes
c'est ça la signification de ce qui doit
être fait et nous devons effectivement
aider ces combattants sur le terrain
mais je suis fortement opposé à ce qu'il
puisse y avoir des militaires français
sur le terrain ce serait vraiment une
très mauvaise analyse en la matière
est-ce qu'il va falloir s'appuyer sur
bachar el-assad pour anéantir l'état
islamique je vous disais tout à l'heure
on a un certain nombre de priorités dans
la vie j'aime pas plus monsieur bachar
al assad que d'autres mais ceci dit je
discutais notamment avec un pasteur
protestant guyer encore à strasbourg qui
dirigent des ong sur le terrain et qui
me disait mais les population syrienne
ne comprennent plus rien à l'occident
ils ne comprennent plus rien à l'europe
est une conteuse line plus rien à la
france
d'abord ils sont à un peu choqué de
certaines de nos attitudes les 10 c'est
quand même sont des pays qui sont
relativement rigoriste
sur le plan des moeurs et ils sont
parfois que choquer deuxièmement ils ne
comprennent pas les revirements sans
arrêt en disant mais un jour bachar
el-assad est reçu dans le pays comme un
chef d'état
le jour suivant on ne lui parle plus il
est démontré il est montré comme un
ennemi le troisième jour on veut re va
lui parler insat louise en sont et ils
disent souvent une chose mais finalement
qu'est ce que des étrangers viennent sur
le terrain régler les problèmes ils
doivent nous aider à régler le problème
c'est pas à eux de décider de ce que
nous devons avoir donc le problème
aujourd'hui
et de mieux faire comprendre d'avoir une
politique qui est une ligne directrice
et qui ne soit pas fait saignante au gré
de ce que veulent bien le dire les états
unis trop souvent et et deuxièmement il
faut savoir établir des priorités
aujourd'hui je le dis très clairement la
priorité c'est la lutte contre des ch
commençons par ça et puis ensuite nous
verrons et en marge de cette actualité
internationale de charger le parlement
poursuit ses travaux c'est l'actualité
du g10 toute la semaine les députés ont
de nouveau examiné le projet de loi
santé défendu par marisol touraine il
prévoit notamment de généraliser le
tiers-payant à l'ensemble des français
ou la mise en place du paquet de
cigarettes neutre une disposition
vivement débattu dans l'hémicycle des
députés ayant voulu supprimer via un
amendement cet article écouter cet
échange entre le député socialiste
sébastien des naja et thierry lazaro
député les républiques je suis pour le
paquet neutre
mise en place en france à la condition
qu'ils le soient en même temps dans
l'ensemble non pas des pays européens
mais au moins dans l'ensemble des pays
frontaliers de la france 3 buralistes
par jour un peu plus ferme aujourd'hui
en france c'est sans oublier non plus ce
qui se paupérise où se font braquer
c'est aussi cela leur quotidien si nous
souhaitons la disparition ou si vous
souhaitez la disparition des buralistes
tant qu'à faire autant le dire tout de
suite michèle alliot-marie vous
comprenez les inquiétudes des buralistes
et ses députés qui disent oui je suis le
lobby des buralistes pour les soutenir
écoutez on peut comprendre les
inquiétudes des buralistes
ils ont un métier comme le vôtre si on
si on vous disait finalement vous
n'allez plus pouvoir exercer votre
métier ou on vous coupe la parole au mot
interdit de dire certains mots qu'il y
ait une réaction c'est tout à fait
normal
ceci dit il ya aussi un vrai problème de
santé publique il faut savoir comment on
réagit moi je vais vous dire j'ai
pratiquement jamais fumé de ma vie
une chose que je sais c'est que je ne
suis pas sûr que simplement avoir un
paquet neutre ce soit ça qui dissuade
véritablement les gens qui ont envie de
fumer de fumée et pendant que
l'assemblée nationale examine le projet
de la santé le sénat lui poursuit
l'examen du projet de loi de finances et
cette semaine il a voté la première
partie du budget la partie recettes non
sans modification jérôme rabier c'est
une première partie du projet de loi de
finances profondément modifier qu'à
voter le sénat à majorité de droite
pour ce volet consacré aux recettes la
haute assemblée est revenu sur de
nombreux aspects touchant à la fiscalité
des ménages ce qui a provoqué des passes
d'armes dans l'hémicycle vous avez
décidé que la question de l'impôt est
avant tout celle de l'impôt des plus
aisés la priorité est de baisser leurs
impôts pour vous quitte à le financer
par une hausse d'impôts sur les classes
moyennes
contre l'avis du gouvernement le sénat a
notamment voté le relèvement du plafond
du quotient familial
l'exonération à 50% de la résidence
principale pour le calcul de l'impôt sur
la fortune et surtout un allègement de
l'imposition des contribuables
assujettis à la tranche des 30 %
c'est la tranche la plus large celle qui
doit notamment les classes moyennes et
ne considérons que c'est une réforme
juste plus juste en tous les cas que
celle proposée par le gouvernement
puisqu'elle va toucher 5 millions de
contribuables
une autre mesure a en revanche fait
consensus contre l'avis du gouvernement
la réduction de la tva sur les
protections hygiéniques féminine
baptisée taxe tampon enfin les sénateurs
ont surtout voté une réduction de
l'effort des collectivités pour réduire
la dépense publique
un effort ramené à 2 milliards d'euros
contre 3,6 milliards souhaité par le
gouvernement une réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement la dgf dont
les sénateurs n'ont pas fini de parler
puisqu'elle est aussi discutée dans le
volet dépenses du projet de loi de
finances on débat jusqu'au 7 décembre
prochain et avant de revenir sur cette
sur ce budget de la louve tous cas du
figaro qui vous interrogera dans
quelques instants
alors michèle alliot marie on l'a
entendu un dans ce sujet le sénat a
réduit la baisse de la dgf la dotation
globale de fonctionnement contre l'avis
du gouvernement
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
l'exécutif fait trop peser sur les
collectivités territoriales l'effort de
réduction du déficit
il est évident que l'exécutif ne peut
pas à la fois se décharger sur les
collectivités d'un certain nombre de ses
obligations compter sur elle notamment
pour assurer une protection de proximité
sur charger la barque notamment avec les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires qui coûte
extrêmement cher aux collectivités leur
demander de participer à des fonds de
péréquation pour aider des collectivités
qui parfois gère d'une façon ou gérer
d'une façon aléatoire leur budget et
d'un autre côté retirer ce qui constitue
encore une part importante du budget de
fonctionnement de ces collectivités
c'est tout à fait normal vous savez vous
avez des collectivités qui ont déjà fait
d'énormes efforts en réduisant un
certain nombre de prestations aux
habitants qui ont fait d'énormes efforts
de réduction de leur personnel je pense
en particulier aux communes et qui
aujourd'hui il n'y arrive plus et
n'arrivent plus à boucler leur budget et
bien sûr c'est facile ensuite pour le
gouvernement de dire s'il ya des
problèmes de mécontentement
adressez-vous caveau mairie et notamment
à vos mérites droite qui sont en général
mieux gérer il faut bien le dire ces
statistiques que des mairies de gauche
c'est dans ce plfr qui ont été
introduites les mesures relatives au
pacte de sécurité est ce que vous pensez
comme françois hollande que le pacte de
sécurité doit primer sur le pacte de
stabilité est coupée il faudrait savoir
d'abord bien sûr là de toute façon la
sécurité doit primer mais il faut aussi
savoir pourquoi la stabilité n'a pas été
atteinte la france le gouvernement
français a fait bas prix 20 ou plus
d'engagement 17 ans et 3% sa vie en 2010
non mais il a pris beaucoup d'engagement
vis-à-vis de l'europe
nous avons vu que ces engagements n'ont
pas été tenus ne seront sans doute pas
tenu
parce que certes il y a eu un certain
nombre d'économies qui ont été faites
certes il ya eu des augmentations
d'impôts considérable nous avons
aujourd'hui les impôts les plus élevés
de toutes les réductions comme beaucoup
je te le dire ça y compris avec les
réductions d'impôts parce que on réduit
des impôts symboliquement et avec
beaucoup de communication sur certains
points et on continue à les
mantes et on les laisse à leur niveau et
sur d'autres points il ne faut pas les
oublier et dans le même temps on a fait
un certain nombre de dépenses ou de
distribution qui n'était absolument pas
obligatoire et qui ont d'ailleurs sur
certains points creuser encore l'écart
avec les autres pays européens
alors que je le rappelle si nous voulons
avoir une europe qui représente un
ensemble susceptibles de se battre
ensemble contre la concurrence
extra-européenne eh bien il faut une
certaine convergence
il faut une convergence en matière
fiscale il faut une convergence en
matière sociale et il faut surtout une
convergence fiscale de façon à ne pas
décourager tous ceux qui travaillent
dans notre pays et qui ont l'impression
qu'ils travaillent et ne s'est pas
simplement une impression ce une réalité
du travail beaucoup plus pour l'état
qu'il ne travaille pour eux mêmes c'est
pas comme ça qu'on motive les gens nous
allons passer aux questions de jean
jaurès et c'est l'heure de l'album this
can bonjour du channel mari on va
revenir sur la journée de mercredi
mercredi soir nicolas sarkozy était en
alsace patrick strasbourg il a prononcé
son premier long discours post attentats
il ya dénoncé les décennies de
renoncement l'affaissement de la
république
la décadence du modèle occidental on
reconnaît derrière ces mots la plume
d'henri guaino qui a rédigé son discours
il a privilégié plus les idées que les
propositions concrètes
est ce que c'est ce qui lui reste après
avoir été un peu corner risée par
françois hollande qui a repris il faut
le dire une grande partie des
propositions qui avaient été émises par
la droite sur ce terrain là écoutez moi
je me réjouis que françois hollande
reprennent les idées aux votants qui
reprennent nos idées parce que je pense
qu'elles sont plus efficaces peut-être
que les siennes le véritable problème
c'est pas simplement qu'ils apprennent
les idées mais c'est qui les met en
oeuvre mais parce que je me dis parfois
que si certaines des propositions que
nous avions faites avait été réellement
mises en oeuvre il y aurait sans doute
des hommes et des femmes qui aujourd'hui
vivre et nicolas sarkozy a donc essayé
de reprendre la hauteur un peu mon à vue
en
discours s qui voulait rompre peut-être
avec la semaine passée qui a été une
semaine d'offensive au niveau des
républicains on se souvient de la séance
des questions au gouvernement qui était
très animé est ce que c'est une façon de
rompre avec cette cette semaine là
égouttez en ce qui concerne la séance
des questions d'actualité moi je regarde
toujours bien qu'il n'y ait pas eu
davantage de tenue et c'est vrai que
cette séance des questions d'actualité
il faudrait quand même un peu y
réfléchir
c'était prendre sans doute une bonne
idée de départ je pense qu'il ya une
certaine dérive aujourd'hui on a voulu
imiter les britanniques n'oublions pas
que les britanniques ne lis pas des
questions et les ministres ne lis pas
les réponses que c'est quelque chose où
quand on ne sait pas quoi répondre en
grande bretagne on dit pas je vous
répondrai par écrit parce que je n'ai
pas vous répondre
ce qui est impossible ici et c'est un
espèce de chaudrons et aussi si je l' ai
connu parce que j'ai dû y passer plus de
1500 que c'est en tout cas ce de choses
comme ça dans tous les ministères que
j'ai occupé donc je connais bien et
c'est vrai que ça n'est pas forcément à
la hauteur de ce que pourrait attendre
nos concitoyens en ce qui concerne
nicolas sarkozy je pense qu'il était
dans son rôle mercredi soir c'est à dire
qu'après cinq jours qui ont été les
jours suivant immédiatement les
attentats finalement il y avait une
certaine sidération de la part de tout
le monde et tout le monde pensait
d'abord aux victimes et à leurs familles
c'est quelque chose d'indispensable
il y à un moment où il faut aussi dire
bon mais alors maintenant qu'est ce que
nous allons faire pour que toutes ces
victimes ne soient pas non plus morte
pour rien c'est à dire que nous sachions
effectivement comment agir
l'une des choses c'est de se regrouper
c'est ce qu'on appelle sur le terme
d'unité nationale et en matière de santé
pourquoi pas l'autre chose c'est de dire
aussi qu est ce que l'on va faire qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire et de ce point de
vue j'espère effectivement que françois
hollande appliquera les mesures que nous
avons préconise alors alain juppé par
lui il a adopté une position un peu
différente
c'était vraiment lui sur l'unité
nationale comme vous disiez il n'a pas
oublié par pour autant de tacler un peu
ses adversaires au sein de son propre
camp
on a nos amis ont notamment entendu
dénoncer la baisse des effectifs
de police lors du quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy vous qui avez été la première
ministre de l'intérieur de ce
quinquennat
qu'est ce que j'ai dit c'est vous enfin
ce qu'il pensait en tant que j'ai été là
il n'ya jamais il n'y a pas eu de baisse
des effectifs de police du
d'effectivement on m'a demandé autant d
alain juppé je vais pas répondre à alain
juppé vous me posez une question je vous
réponds à vous il n'y a pas eu de baisse
des effectifs de police tant que j'ai
été ministre de l'intérieur quand on
nous a demandé des efforts budgétaires
je les ai faits portés sur les services
administratifs et je pense que c'est
comme ça que l'on devrait faire
et effectivement moi je regrette qu'il y
ait eu des diminutions de budget dans la
police mais aussi dans la défense
nationale et notamment sur nos armées
françois hollande a été obligé de
revenir sur des décisions qu'il avait
prises
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est
effectivement remettre la défense comme
la police ou rang qui doit être comme le
leur c'est à dire au premier rang et
j'inclus d'ailleurs aussi la justice
dont je dis que la justice a besoin si
on veut que finalement elles suivent les
délinquants qui sont arrêtés par la
police
bien d'avoir les moyens de le faire
dernière question ce matin pour terminer
la république vous y étiez un d'ailleurs
aux invalides a rendu hommage aux
victimes des attentats pour l'occasion
un françois hollande avait demandé aux
français de pavoiser c'est son
expression les les façades des maisons
des immeubles des drapeaux français
est ce que la gauche a trop souvent trop
longtemps abandonnés ce symbole de la
république française
écoutez moi je suis gaulliste je suis
française et je suis gaulliste et pour
moi le drapeau national ça une
signification et effectivement je me
retrouve derrière ce drapeau et c'est
vrai que j'ai parfois eu les larmes aux
yeux quand j'étais à l'étranger et que
j'ai vu hissé le drapeau français et ça
me fait quelque chose et il ce que je
dis c'est que chaque français doit se
sentir en tant que tel nous n'avons pas
besoin de recommandations de pavoiser
les français doivent et ayons le droit
de mettre le drapeau chaque fois qu'ils
en ressentent l'envié et le besoin et ça
ça me parait effectivement une bonne
chose que de rappeler que la france
c'est un drapeau que ça représente une
histoire dans lequel beaucoup d'hommes
et de femmes se sont sacrifiés pour
nous puissions être aujourd'hui ce que
nous sommes et ça doit être aussi un
modèle qui peut être donnée à certains y
compris dans notre pays merci beaucoup
du monument on parlait à l'instant de ce
vendredi jour d'hommage national
françois hollande qui a présidé la
cérémonie d'hommage national qui s'est
tenu aux invalides le chef de l'état qui
dans son discours a évoqué cette
génération devenue le visage de la
france son écoute
je salue cette génération nouvelle elle
a été frappée elle n'est pas effrayée
elle est lucide et entreprenante
à l'image des innocents deux nous
portons le deuil elle saura j'en suis
convaincu faire preuve de grandeur
elle vivra elle vivra pleinement au nom
des morts que nous pleurons aujourd'hui
malgré les larmes
cette génération est aujourd'hui devenue
le visage de la france
michèle alliot marie on a entendu
certaines familles elle était très
critique à l'encontre du gouvernement
elle pointe la responsabilité de l'état
et ce qu'elle existe cette
responsabilité écoutez la responsabilité
elle sera établie par les enquêtes par
la justice le cas échéant ou par
l'émission que parlementaire encore une
fois bon à un attentat c'est toujours
quelque chose d'imprévisible simplement
il y a une responsabilité morale
personnelle ou au delà de ça qui
consiste pour chacun à se dire est ce
que j'ai fait tout ce que je devais
faire ou est ce que j'ai fait tout ce
que je pouvais faire et je pense que
nous en avons déjà parlé tout à l'heure
il faut autant en tous les cas se sentir
responsables chacun de faire ce que ce
qui doit être fait alors ça s'adresse
effectivement au gouvernement ça
s'adresse au parlement
ça s'adresse aussi à chacun des citoyens
parce que la france c'est ça et moi je
me réjouis aujourd'hui de dire que la
france ne baisse pas les bras
surtout devant le terrorisme surtout
devant l'injustice la france est fière
doit être fier d'être elle-même merci
beaucoup michèle alliot-marie merci
d'avoir refait la semaine avec nous
merci allizard maire syrienne et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires font à nouveau
parler boulot